[Music]
shortly after isaac newton wrote down
his famous universal law of gravitation
another englishman an english clergyman
in fact raised a startling prospect
here's a basic idea
if you fire a projectile say a
cannonball if you fire it upward at an
ordinary velocity earth gravity will be
able to slow its ascent and pull it back
to the ground and if you launch the
cannonball with a higher velocity it
will reach a greater height before being
pulled back and here's the point if you
launch it with sufficiently large
velocity the cannonball will actually be
able to
escape from the earth and continue its
outward journey a launch speed that we
call unsurprisingly the escape velocity
on earth this escape velocity is about
11 kilometers per second so anything
shot upward with the speed greater than
that will not be pulled back to earth's
surface and on a planet that's more
massive than the earth the greater
gravitational pull will yield a larger
escape velocity
now the english clergyman i mentioned
before john mitchell
he realized that you could apply the
very same reasoning to the light that is
racing away from a star like the sun
i mean the reason starlight escapes from
the sun is because the speed of light
which is enormous
is greater than the sun's escape
velocity
so light produced by the sun can escape
and travel out into space
and that's why we can see the sun but
what if mitchell wondered you consider a
star that's more massive than the sun
well with more mass
the gravitational pull is stronger so
the escape velocity increases so
you can imagine
increasing a star's mass so much that
the escape velocity grows larger than
the velocity of light at which point
light itself
cannot escape and so the star will fade
to black which is perhaps the earliest
suggestion of the possibility
of what we now call
black holes
mitchell made that observation way back
in the 1700s we now fast forward a
couple of hundred years
albert einstein comes up with his
general theory of relativity a more
refined version of gravity than newton's
theory and shortly thereafter another
deep thinker carl schwarzschild he plays
a similar role for einstein as mitchell
did for newton because schwartz child
realizes that
if you take a massive object like a star
you somehow
squeeze its size smaller and smaller
the gravitational pull would become so
concentrated
that anything that gets too close closer
than what we call the event horizon will
not be able to escape the gravitational
grip and since anything includes light
itself we again encounter the prospect
of dark stars that is black holes
now einstein himself resisted the notion
of black holes even though the concept
emerged from the very equations he had
spent 10
long years developing he was
he was troubled by the fact that the
mathematics broke down at the black
hole's deep interior the so-called
singularity but
even beyond that i think it's fair to
say that einstein also had a
overall resistance because black holes
just seemed to him to be
too extreme to be real
nevertheless through the decades
especially in the decades after einstein
died the case for black holes continued
to grow
on the theoretical front physicists
gained an understanding of how black
holes might actually form from
massive stars that
use up all of their nuclear fuel and so
they implode in on themselves perhaps
creating a black hole and on the
observational front
data in support of black holes came from
studying the motion of stars whose
extreme speeds and trajectories seem to
suggest that they
must be orbiting a black hole
but as these advances make clear the
case for black holes remained decidedly
indirect the the old adage seeing as
believing is one that seemingly could
not be applied to black holes
but as it turns out it can and now it
has
thanks to the work of the event horizon
telescope we now have
direct images taken by radio telescopes
of two black holes the most recent is a
remarkable image of the black hole in
the center of our own
milky way galaxy and tonight we will
speak with the leader of the event
horizon telescope collaboration shep
dolmen about these spectacular
achievements
[Music]
shep dolmen is an astrophysicist at the
harvard smithsonian center for
astrophysics and the founding director
of the event horizon telescope
collaboration
he led the international team that three
years ago produced the first ever direct
image of a black hole in a distant
galaxy called m87 and recently the event
horizon telescope unveiled yet another
startling image the supermassive black
hole at the heart of our own galaxy
called sagittarius a star
shep joins us from cambridge
massachusetts
welcome chef hey brian
so chef congratulations on this
incredible achievement of
this first
image of the black hole in the center of
our milky way galaxy uh i gather this is
actually the culmination of of decades
of of hard work and and perseverance i
mean where did this journey begin for
you first of all thank you it's a real
incredible moment to see this image swim
into focus
it started for me in the early 90s when
i got hooked on this technique of
turning the earth into a virtual
telescope using the actual confines of
the planet to create a telescope it's
called very long baseline interferometry
and i was
just enraptured by the magic of it that
you could
receive radio waves from a black hole on
different parts of the earth record data
at each of these sites bring them
together and then you got a data set as
though you had a telescope as large as
the distance between
these telescopes and we did it you know
in the early 90s at a wavelength of
three millimeters
again looking at sagittarius a star
super massive black holes and we didn't
have enough angular resolution to really
see all the way to the event horizon and
that began this journey of now
like 25 26 27 years to the point where
we can actually make images of black
holes
in terms of the actual equipment
presumably you were using existing radio
telescopes and putting them together
into a network or did you actually have
to go out and imagine building anything
from scratch well the nice thing about
this technique that we're using in the
event horizon telescope is that we can
take
specialized bespoke electronics to
existing sites and then form a network
so they can do something that no one of
those telescopes could do by themselves
and
by networking them with atomic clocks
you know high-speed internet you know
high-speed recording devices
we can create a telescope that has the
highest angular resolution
of of anything that we can muster from
the planet so it's a new kind of
telescope and it's specialized to do
this one kind of thing it's a highly
specialized technique that allows us to
see into the heart of these black holes
and so where are the telescopes that you
use as part of the event horizon
telescope network in the early days we
had a few telescopes you know hawaii
california arizona and that was enough
to take the measure of the black hole we
were able to see the size of it but not
actually make a picture of one but now
we have a network all over the globe so
we start in the south pole we come up to
chile we have alma and the opex stations
there then we come to the large
millimeter telescope in mexico two
telescopes the james clerk maxwell
telescope and the sma
in hawaii we have two telescopes now in
arizona kitt peak and mount graham two
telescopes in europe noema in france and
the iran 30 meter in spain and one and
also in greenland and we network them
all together to make this virtual
telescope is it right to imagine that
say as the earth is turning that each of
these telescopes is sort of sweeping out
a swath of the sky and then you are
basically compositing from the data that
each of these telescopes is able to
measure from its radio telescope
analyses yeah that's exactly right but
with one slight tweak it's the baseline
between a pair of telescopes that gives
us a fundamental data point so two
telescope pairs two telescopes shaking
hands if you will that gives us one
pixel
in in our image or relates to one pixel
in the image so you think about all the
different ways that all the telescopes
could shake hands
and that gives you an idea how much data
you have and then as the earth turns
all those connections change in
orientation and they change in projected
length to the black hole so you wind up
filling out this virtual
telescope as the earth rotates so it's
all a little magic to me still i mean
after 30 years i still pinch myself that
this this works as well as it does but
you know we're able to
have that
the earth is just the right size we're
able to observe it just the right
frequency so the angular resolution of
this earth-sized telescope is just
enough
to image the supermassive black hole in
the center of our galaxy i mean you
can't make this up it's a little bit
like
the how the eclipse works you know you
see a
you know total eclipse of the sun
because the moon exactly fits over the
sun allowing us to see things that would
be normally hidden from us and the same
way we use the earth to see things that
are normally hidden around the black
hole and so were there dark days
in this
quest
places where you thought this approach
might not bear fruit
oh yeah it's uh there were some low
moments in this whole journey
um we realized in the late 90s that we
just didn't have the sensitivity to make
these measurements we needed long base
lines we needed telescopes very you know
far separated on the earth to make this
measurement
but it also means you need exquisite
sensitivity at all these sites
and one thing that limited us was the
bandwidth we just didn't have the
bandwidth of our recording at each of
these sites to be able to see
these supermassive black holes so there
was a revolution
in the early 2000s where we
hitched our wagon to commodity
electronics we just bought hard disks
you know from from commodity vendors we
used high-speed electronics that were
just becoming available and we rode this
moore's law curve this doubling of
capacity about every 18 months and
instead of designing specialized
electronics in the lab we assembled them
from high-speed components and that
proved to be instrumental i mean that
was the big difference and we were able
to over about 15 years
increase the bandwidth of our systems by
a hundred that's unheard of
in astronomy right so we increased our
capacity by a hundred and that increased
our sensitivity by tenfold it goes as
the square root of the bandwidth and
that allowed us to make the first
detections in 2008
but before then
we had some dramatic failures i mean i
remember one
moment where we decamped to hawaii also
to arizona we set everything up months
of painstaking
preparation
and we found absolutely nothing
absolutely nothing it was crushing
and the reason is that a small tiny chip
of metal
had fallen into the superconducting
receiver the camera in hawaii and nobody
knew about it and it was rattling around
in there
you know ruining the phase coherence of
the entire earth-sized telescope and it
was only months later that we realized
what happened
so
we we picked ourselves up you know we
did it the next year and we were
successful wow
that's a
you know amazing story where i can
imagine morale
dropped at that point especially i mean
you've got graduate students who are
trying to finish their phd and so forth
that rely on that kind of data
um and so did you find that you had to
sort of go around and
pump people back up to get the
enthusiasm
where it needed to be to undertake these
kind of missions well
there were two things going on it was it
was a moment when
we were pretty low
but
we understood
at that moment that it was a technical
problem and that's really important a
technical problem you can solve i mean
that's what we do we get up every
morning we eat technical problems with
breakfast frankly
but if it was something like there was a
physical
quality about the source that would have
prevented us from seeing the event
horizon that would have been a deal
breaker so for example if we had seen
sagittarius a-star in those early
experiments but it had been too big it
had been so tufty that we were seeing
some outer scattering surface and we
couldn't pierce all the way to the event
horizon then we would have sort of
packed up and gone home but if it was
just a technical problem then we of
course we pressed on and yeah i you know
as as the band leader i had to get
everybody you know back on track
reassure people yes we have the funding
to do this next year
and and in fact we went back the next
year and added an antenna and that was
really important because when you have a
triangle then you're
able to withstand the failure of one
site and you should still detect the
source on the others right so that gave
us a big backup and that made everybody
feel a lot better about going out the
next year so on the flip side when you
first got your image say of a
supermassive black hole i guess the
first one was uh uh m87 uh not
sagittarius a star
i mean what's it like when when these
images finally appear is everyone
standing around a monitor waiting for
the data to coalesce and see what the
image looks like oh well it takes a long
time frankly to process the data so so
first the data have to be flown back to
a central processing facility we record
them on hard disks and nothing beats the
bandwidth
of a 747 filled with hard disk drives it
just beats any high speed internet on
the planet so you wait for these to come
back and in some cases you have to wait
for the data to come back from a very
remote site like the south pole that can
take months for the data to come back
because the south pole station closes
down and only opens up after about six
months after you've taken the data
and then you have to crunch the data you
have to align
down to the picosecond the data streams
that you recorded at each of these sites
you play them back you combine them
and then you have to go through a
painstaking process of calibrating those
you've got to go from ones and zeros to
brightness on the sky
and then after you do that then you have
to do your imaging
it it's a very long process and when
you're trying to image something that
you've never imaged before
you're very careful
and so we checked it once twice three
times we tried to make rings go away
we looked at calibrator sources that we
knew were not rings to make sure that we
were not manufacturing rings when there
were no rings
a very very long process so it's not
this is not a polaroid camera right but
what is it like when the image finally
does
emerge from the data set oh
so in 2018
we all met it
at harvard
at the black hole initiative and we had
four teams that had separately been
working on the m87 image and even though
they had all the same data
no team was allowed to talk to another
team we did want not want to have group
think where everybody starts seeing one
thing and says oh yeah i see that too
and it's a very real thing in the
sciences as
and not just in astronomy and so we we
walled everyone off everyone went to
their corners worked on the data and
then we came back
and there was one moment
when all four images that nobody had
ever seen before were on the screen
and each one of them different
techniques different teams you know
different approaches they all showed
this ring
and that
was an incredible moment there was like
audible gasps from the crowd
uh you know because everyone had thought
well i see a ring but does everyone else
see a ring and when we saw that everyone
was seeing this and the signature was so
clear
that is when we got extremely excited
and the emotions
was is a mixture at that point of awe
humility like wonder relief
you know exasperation but also
just you know incredu being incredulous
it was it was
an amazing feeling yeah i mean there's
there's the drama of scientific
discovery so it's uh amazing so i want
to take a step back
and talk a little bit about the science
of black holes in order to place the
images that you and your team
have acquired so we can just sort of see
how they fit into the history of
thinking on the subject
and the the history takes us right back
to albert einstein who in 1915 wrote
down
the famous field equations of the
general theory of relativity and and
here those equations are
the audience doesn't need to know these
equations but the important point is
with this mathematics we now had a
analytical tool for understanding
gravity
and what it does to the structure of
space and time in a way that we didn't
have before but it wasn't einstein right
who came up with the mathematical
solution that suggests the possibility
of black holes right it was uh carl
schwarzschild who's a german
mathematician and it's kind of an
amazing thing right because he's the
first person to come up with an exact
mathematical solution to einstein's
equations and and within that math we
see the possibility of black holes so we
can see the solution that schwarzschild
came up with again the math of the
schwarzschild metric is not going to be
our focus here but i just want to
point out two things that you can speak
to so in this equation
even even a high school kid who's just
learned that you can't divide through by
zero
see some funny things in
this mathematics right because they're
two special places
that
that again even a high school kid could
point out uh when r which is the uh
distance from the center of this object
is either equal to zero or a special
value that we can see they're 2g m over
c squared there's funny things that
happen there so
can you just give us a sense of of of
what it is that that the math suggests
might be happening at those two special
locations yeah so first of all
the history of this project leads as you
say right back to einstein and what i
like to say is that we're in the process
of having a conversation with einstein a
virtual conversation with einstein and
schwarzschild uh i call it a 100-year
handshake you know that we have this
compact with them that we're carrying on
a lot of the ideas that they've they
formulated and this equation is that's
exactly what it is it's it shows you
that at the event horizon that there is
a boundary
around
the the central
mass condensation
at which the escape speed equals that of
light
right so if even light at that point
cannot escape and you know we can go up
to that point and still
you know come back out but once you
cross that point everything changes the
whole space-time metric changes in a way
that you are inexorably drawn to the
center right so the whole coordinate
systems really change fundamentally you
know from being you know space-like
outside to time-like inside and once you
go through you can never come back out
no information can come back out in a
normal way from the interior of the
black hole in fact since we have that
equation if you might not even just
describe so when r is bigger than the
schwarzschild radius the event horizon
then the metric has a certain character
and just for the mathematical focus on
our audience when r becomes less than
the source of radius what you're saying
is the sign of the spatial part and the
temporal part they interchange so in
some sense the radial direction goes
from being a space direction to a time
direction which gives some understanding
of why it is you can't escape from a
black hole just like you can't stay at a
given moment in time
you can't stay at a given distance from
the center because it's a temporal
coordinate at that point you're drawn to
the singularity with the same force that
drags each and every one of us to the
next moment in time that's the power of
of a black hole and so your goal your
goal was to turn this mathematics
into
an actual image of something out there
in the universe but
einstein himself
was skeptical
that
the black hole solution even was it
wasn't called that in his day he was
skeptical that black holes would be real
right what was his hesitation for
believing in this strange possibility
you know that's a it's above my pay
grade to get into the mind of einstein
sure mine too mine too
yeah
i wish i wish i were at that pay grade
um
so
einstein enjoyed the fact i think that
there was this mathematical possibility
i mean who wouldn't
i mean all of a sudden you have this
beautiful equations you're convinced
that they work you're convinced that
they govern the universe they explain
the perihelion shift of mercury they
resolve a number of outstanding problems
that have bedeviled astronomers and
physicists for a long time
and all of a sudden somebody from you
know the front in world war one writes a
postcard to you and says oh by the way
i've solved your equations and here's
this weird solution and if all the
matter is in a point there's this event
horizon
and what do you think and
einstein presents it to the prussian
academy of sciences and i think he
thought this is weird but it'll never
happen
it just is not going to happen right so
this is a weird mathematical construct
no basis in reality but you know fast
forward you know about 15 years you know
or you know 25 years and oppenheimer and
snyder were too you know well-known uh
physicist oppenheimer uh from the the
bomb effort
they
look at whether or not
there's a material way for matter to
condense
right whether gravitation could
inexorably draw matter together and they
show pretty clearly that yes there is a
way for this to happen and at the same
time the same year even
einstein is publishing a paper that says
i don't buy this i don't think that this
can actually happen so in the same year
you've got these two titans you know
oppenheimer
and and einstein just coming at this
from different avenues and i think that
einstein just had a mindset
that nature would not allow this to
happen he had this idea that
if you modeled matter trying to fall
onto a black hole as orbiting balls
that at some point the balls would have
to go faster than the speed of light
when they approached the event horizon
he said can't happen
and oppenheimer and snyder said well you
can have radial inflow and there's
nothing that can stop it there's you
know you can pass through the event
horizon
if you're an observer and you don't
you might be you might get spaghettified
but you can pass through the event
horizon right and einstein thought no
you'll never be able to pass through the
event horizon so you had
we we forget that this was formative
times these are weighty issues right
people don't always get it right the
first time around and you know
oppenheimer einstein they're wrestling
with it they really are i mean just to
give people a sense
if you
take an ordinary astrophysical object
just take our sun
if you wanted it to be a black hole i
mean how much would you have to have it
crushed down how dense would its matter
have to be packed to turn into a black
hole right so the the touchstone for our
sun is that it would have to be three
kilometers across
you know like one and a half miles you
know the entire mass of the sun
condensed into something
that that small which is crazy sounding
right
to imagine that so you can sort of i i
don't know that that was einstein's main
motivation for being skeptical but
certainly when you hear about that at
first sight it's like how could that
possibly happen now as you say
the oppenheimer schneider work gives a
possible mechanism of a stellar collapse
but
we're talking pretty exotic stuff here
oh absolutely i think that for that time
these were these were crazy ideas i mean
it would have been equivalent to an
intellectual revolution
for someone like einstein to accept this
kind of thing and you forget he's no
stranger to revolution i mean you know
he kind of said newton i'm sorry but
there's this new way of understanding
gravity so he's not shy
but at the same time
you know this would involve changes in
how the night sky would appear i mean
you'd really need to see some exotic
objects on the sky and at that time they
didn't know that supermassive black
holes existed in the center of all the
galaxies right they didn't have a clear
understanding of pulsars which had not
yet been discovered there was a whole
range of observations
that slowly started building the case
for this exotic zoo
of cosmic objects out there and if
einstein had come along and he'd
been thinking about this in the 80s for
example after quasars had been
discovered their ultraluminous centers
of galaxies after pulsars had been
discovered one might imagine
that he would have said you know there
are some crazy things out there i better
rethink this like i better not you know
think in this way of orbiting balls like
maybe there's some other exotic things
so
we are in our time we think about these
deep thoughts in our time
and and i think that's part of it
so what was the evidence that began to
build that there is a black hole in the
center of our galaxy
so it built slowly i mean we started to
see in the 70s
uh well in the city in the 60s you know
pulsars
were
were coming on the scene so we knew
there was ultra dense matter
you know spinning these lighthouses that
were beacons of flashes of radio light
uh in in the 70s we started to get ideas
of x-ray binaries where you would have
an unseen mass devouring a star
that was orbiting it
you know producing copious amounts of
x-rays and the only way to really
understand that would be
a black hole devouring an accretion flow
a nearby star
and we also began to look at the centers
of gra of galaxies and we could see in
aggregate the motions of stars and the
motion of gas around the center of these
galaxies
and
the profile was that there was something
extremely massive at the center of these
galaxies not to mention the fact that we
could see
in these distant galaxies very bright
central cores
and sometimes these cores could outshine
the aggregate light of all the stars
in a galaxy this got people thinking
maybe there is something there that is
incredibly efficient
that can
cause this luminosity and of course
supermassive black holes attracting
matter
turning that gravitational potential
energy into radiant light
is one of the most efficient engines
we know of in the cosmos that got people
thinking that black holes existed exotic
ideas
were real and that these supermassive
black holes existed in the centers of
galaxies
and then in particular for for our
galaxy
the work of uh andrei ghez and ryan
argenzo i mean these are they were
recently worth the nobel prize can you
just take us
a little bit through the insight that
they gave to this puzzle of the
existence of a black hole in the center
of our galaxy
yeah the so the center of our galaxy is
special right because once people knew
that there were probably supermassive
black holes in extra galactic sources
the hunt was on to find our supermassive
black hole because just as our sun
is an incredible way to learn about
stars
if we had one of these super massive
black holes in our galaxy we could study
it up close
and personal and make some inferences
about what was happening in distant
galaxies you know very strong draw
in 74
balak and brown two astronomers two
radio astronomers detected a very
compact radio source in the heart of the
constellation sagittarius which is in
the center of the milky way towards the
center of the milky way and
they named that sagittarius a star and
that was that marked the position of
what we now know is a 4 million solar
mass black hole
and over the over the next decade or so
radio interferometers
with higher and higher angular
resolution narrowed the size of this
object to the point where
it
it was very looking very much like a
black hole i mean what else could be a
tiny tiny dot in the center of our
galaxy that was producing so much energy
and the work of andrea guez and reinhard
genzel
really took this to the next level
because they looked at the orbits of
stars
you know at first
you know looking at in aggregate the
motions of stars but then individual
orbits of stars around an unseen mass
and i remember when i first saw that
work
in in the mid 90s and the late 90s
and then the 2000s
you know it knocked my socks off
it just did because here was you know
clear proof that there was something a
compact object that weighed millions of
times what our sun does
tossing
stars around like planets
it was a real sobering moment it's one
of those moments when you realize the
cosmos has some big monsters out there
but even so
and that motivated my work too and the
work of the event horizon telescope to
keep pushing because if there was
something
that was that compact if there were to
be a black hole at the center of the
milky way galaxy we should be able to
image it turn it into
on horizon scales one of the most
extreme laboratories in the entire
universe to study einstein to study
physics
it's interesting they won the nobel
prize
for the discovery of a compact object
and because the stars are so are still
so far away from the central mass
that they couldn't clearly state that it
was a black hole
i mean you can you can ask yourself what
else could it be
you know you can
try to use the process of elimination to
come to that conclusion but those stars
are still a thousand schwarzschild radii
away from the black hole so if newton
looked at the orbits of those stars he
would still be able to trace them out
fairly accurately you have to have
extreme precision to start to see slight
deviations from newtonian gravity
and they have done that now but the case
for a black hole was still open and that
was i think recognized by the nobel
prize committee
and so the motivation was strong
in that there's this indirect evidence
that there's a black hole there but
until you kind of see it
you don't really have the evidence that
establishes that it is a black hole so
can can we take a look then in a little
more detail at the image that you
recently released of the black hole in
the center of our galaxy and can you can
you just walk us through
what what we're actually seeing in this
image in a little bit more detail
sure
uh when you look at this image what what
you're seeing is light bent around the
black hole so the gravity well is so
deep the gravity is so strong that light
is constrained to move in orbits
around the black hole so what you're
seeing primarily here is light from
behind the black hole lensed around
towards us
now and the center is there because some
of those light rays hit the event
horizon and they're lost forever so you
wind up getting a natural depression in
the center
and a ring outside which
is very close to the photon orbit right
so you're looking at
the real you you're you're looking at
space-time laid bare can you just remind
us can you remind us what the photon
orbit is it's a important concept sure
so so the
black hole is defined by the event
horizon once light goes through the
event horizon it's lost forever but
outside of that just a little bit
outside of that
there's a point where light can orbit in
a circle where it's confined forever to
be on on an orbit we call that the
photon orbit right and the ring of light
you see there is defined by the grazing
incidence photons that just
escape that orbit like if they if they
went onto that orbit they would be bound
forever if they are slightly inside of
that orbit they spiral in and they're
lost
the ones that graze the outside
that is what you wind up seeing that is
bent to our line of sight so
we can't see the event horizon perfectly
but we can see this clear mathematical
boundary called the photon orbit and
that's what you're seeing and because
the einstein's equations that we saw
before
tell us exactly
the size of that photon orbit we can lay
a ruler across this image and we can
test einstein's theory
now you'll see it's tufty right and
that's because there's a lot of hot gas
moving around so there are many
different sight lines many different
points where the gas is bright enough
that it releases energy and all that is
being bent around so there is a width
to that ring
but in in general if you draw a midline
ridge through that ring that will be
very close to the photon orbit
and and so presumably you can take
einstein's equations and put them on a
powerful supercomputer and you can
simulate what you would expect to see
and compare with what you actually do
and and how do those those line up i
mean you mentioned you know one test you
know the uh the photon orbit
how about overall does einstein come
through with flying colors are there
various small differences that one needs
to figure out as you continue the
research so if you talk about testing
einstein the stars orbiting the black
hole that work by andrea guez and
reinhard gensel that gives you some
really interesting tests of einstein's
theory around a black hole
in the low field regime because they're
still very far from the black hole this
is testing einstein
at the boundary you can't get any closer
than this like this is it like
we've gotten as far as we're going go on
on these black holes now the the
the test that we ran here shows that
einstein is right at about you know the
10 to 20 percent level and that's just
because the width of this ring because
of the gas orbiting around
uh
presents us with some of the
uncertainties but it's going to get much
better in the future right because we
know very well what the mass of sahaja
star is so as we refine these images
we'll make better and better tests this
is just the beginning brian
and that's the that's the very cool
thing about it you know i definitely
would love to in a couple minutes come
to where you expect this work to go but
just to finish up the discussion of uh
sagittarius a star
um
how far away is it and how big is it i
mean how hard is it to to take that
image what what are the scales that are
involved here
so sagittarius a star is the center of
our galaxy about you know 26 27
000 light years distant from us
and the size of this ring is about 50
micro arc seconds black holes are the
smallest objects
predicted by einstein's gravity so this
image
equivalent to being able to see an
orange on the moon an orange on the moon
an orange or your favorite citrus
favorite fruit probably because yeah
yeah if you're allergic to oranges
something else
uh it's also equivalent to being able to
see an atom if you held it at arm's
length
so if this gives you some idea of the
angular resolution that we're that we
have to achieve in order to see this
yeah by the way the reason that you're
seeing light
around a black hole you might ask well
if the black hole swallows light
how do we even see anything
that's coming from it
so the the black hole in the center of
our galaxy is being fed by dust and gas
from stars that are around the black
hole
and all that gas tries madly to get into
an extremely small space
and as you can imagine when you rub your
hands together it heats up but in this
case it heats up to tens even hundreds
of billions of degrees
so the black hole is surrounded in a
paradox of its own gravity by this
extremely luminous plasma
or very hot gas
and in that way the space time of the
black hole is being illuminated by a
three-dimensional flashlight i mean from
every direction the space time is being
illuminated so we see
the the space-time laid bare because we
can see it from every angle the light
gets bent around and we see a true
reflection
of
what einstein predicts
and and so
one would have thought that the first
black hole image that your team would
release would have been the nearby black
hole nearby in quotes you know 26 000
light years
but it but it wasn't so the first image
that you guys released a few years back
was of a far more distant
black hole so can you tell us about that
and tell us why in the world was that
the target that you initially
provided to the world of an image of a
black as opposed to the one in our own
neighborhood in in 2017 we observed both
these black holes both sagittarius a
star in the center of the milky way and
m87 which is 55 million light years away
in the virgo a galaxy
and
we looked at both of these data sets
and we started to calibrate both data
sets
and in the case of m87 it was pretty
clear that we were seeing a ring just
from some of the raw data we saw
something very interesting just from the
raw data
and there's a very physical reason why
that would be the case
m87 is so large that during a night of
observing during a night of data taking
by the event horizon telescope it
doesn't change its shape
it's so big that light takes three weeks
to orbit
m87
so
it's like taking a still image
with your camera sagittarius a star is a
thousand times
less massive and that means it evolves a
thousand times faster so light you know
orbits
the the black hole there in minutes
so over during the course of of a night
it can change its shape it's like trying
to take a picture of of somebody moving
across your field of view it's very
blurry or somebody dancing you wind up
seeing a world of arms and legs and it's
all a blur you can't really see
what you're looking at so we decided
to focus on the m87 data come with this
first image make our first test of
einstein you know come with conclusive
evidence that super massive black holes
existed in the centers of galaxies
and and begin to test our theories of
accretion and outflow around black holes
and we put sage star on the shelf a
little bit but we knew we were always
going to come back to that because it's
one of the it's the object of our
obsession really
and but we had to
come with algorithms
that could handle the the dynamism
of sagittarius a star so we had to think
about taking small snapshots little
snippets of data where sanjay star would
be stationary where it would be
one frame of a movie
and then stitch these together
make averages and then come with the
image that you see on the right here but
then that took another two years for us
to come with the mathematics and the
algorithms to allow us to do that and so
how massive is the the first black hole
image in m87 you said it a thousand
times so we're talking billions of times
the mass of the sun presumably here no
it's
it is mind-blowing the the massive at
the m87 black hole is six and a half
billion times
the mass of our sun and what you're
seeing there is
six and a half billion suns
trapped within
the photon orbit i mean that is the
conclusive proof
that these black holes do exist and on
the right is sagittarius a star no it's
it's puny in comparison
but it's still four million times the
mass of our sun again with all that mass
confined to within
this uh this orbit that light takes
around it so are there any particularly
interesting differences between or
similarities between the two images that
are worth pointing out yeah
so
i like to say that if i was trapped on a
desert island with two super massive
black holes these would be the ones
m87
is a distant supermassive black hole it
powers a relativistic jet so it issues
from it spinning the black hole is
spinning and from the north and south
poles there are jets and material that
pierce the entire galaxy it's like a
blow torch across tens of thousands of
light years so it's it is a
monster it's one of the
most massive black holes we know of in
the sky it powers this extremely
energetic phenomena you would not want
to be in the way
of that jet right and it inhabits an
elliptical galaxy that's huge by
galactic standards
so that's
m87 and in addition
on that
image you'll see the bottom part is
brighter than the top part
this is fairly conclusive proof that the
black hole is spinning the black hole is
forcing gas close to the black hole to
move around with it the bright part on
the bottom is because gas is coming
towards us at near light speed so it's
doppler boosted it seems brighter and on
the top it's fainter because it's moving
away from us so you see a clear
asymmetry that gives you a window into
the
the spin
of the black hole and this orientation
on the sky
by contrast
sage star is our own
super massive black hole it's in it's in
our backyard
and if it was at the distance of m87 we
would never see it it's that bright but
at the same time it's emblematic and
it's representative of most supermassive
black holes in your average galaxy so
while m87 is this exotic
huge galaxy we live in a spiral galaxy
that looks like most other galaxies so
m87 allows us to study the outliers
while saggy star allows us to study what
happens very close end or very close
into our galaxy but also
it allows us to study most galaxies
now
you'll notice that there are blotches on
the sanjay star image
we don't really believe the exact
location of all those blotches because
we think it's due to the fact that
sagittarius a star is dancing while
we're trying to take this image we do
believe the central
depression
the dark spot in the middle we
absolutely are convinced and believe
this ring structure
but the structure or the changing
structure around the ring that's
something that we're going to have to
refine over time will probably require
us to make true movies of these
so is that is that where some of the
work is headed to create dynamic imagery
not just these still images absolutely
so for example the size of these rings
is predicted by einstein's theory the
fact that we've seen two of them
is extraordinary evidence now
that einstein's theory holds but also
the black holes do exist in the centers
of these galaxies
but
the size of that black hole is somewhat
insensitive to spin
so if you if you have a non-spinning
black hole called a schwarzschild black
hole or you know maximally spinning
black will occur black hole the size of
the shadow stays roughly the same
you can get some asymmetries but the
size of the shadow stays the same
now imagine you had matter orbiting the
black hole imagine you were in a
spaceship you turned off the motor and
you were moving around the black hole
the orbital period how long it takes you
to go around the black hole that's
exquisitely sensitive to spin
so for example for for sagittarius a
star if you were orbiting in the
direction that the black hole was
spinning you could make that trip in
four minutes
but if you were moving in the opposite
direction of the spin it would take you
an hour
so now we have a way of testing with
great precision the spin of the black
hole so one of the reasons we'd like to
make movies is if we can track the
motion of matter around the black hole
we would be able to say what the spin of
sanjay star was or what the spin of m87
was we'd be able to disentangle things
like orientation on the sky
you know the way it the black hole spin
is is oriented in relation to our line
of sight there's a lot of things that we
can do in the future
with these images and with movies it
seems like in this case einstein was
kind of maximally wrong
not only
are black holes do they exist but there
seem to be relatively commonplace you
know in the centers of galaxies
where are we in understanding why
they are so commonplace why are black
holes in the center massive supermassive
black holes in the center of so many
perhaps all galaxies this is this is one
of the great mysteries like why do we
see supermassive black holes in just
about every galactic core
it has a lot to do we think with the
co-evolution
of supermassive black holes and galaxies
you know there's a chicken and egg
question
do you first start getting stars that
then form small black holes that then
merge and coalesce into larger black
holes they sink to the center of large
gas clouds they then seed
more star formation
these are very complex simulations to
run and we really don't know exactly
which comes first exactly which stage
the black hole shines most brightly at
and then allows to
the the galaxy to come in and and form
more with more structure but there are
wonderful simulations
that look at large sections of the
universe and you wind up seeing many of
these different phenomena happening but
on the galactic scale
it must be that
you wind up with smaller black holes
they then nucleate some of these
galaxies these small galaxies collide
the central black holes then merge form
a larger galaxy so it's a mixture of gas
star formation hierarchical merging it's
very complex but somehow we wind up with
the night sky that we have
where each galaxy has a black hole at
its center
and do you imagine at some point
focusing your attention on black holes
that are not at the center of galaxies i
mean you know ligo laser interferometer
interferometer gravitational wave
observatory gave us
evidence through a different signature
through gravitational waves of the
existence of much smaller
black holes are those ever going to be a
target or are they just too small to
ever hope to have this kind of direct
imaging of we can't measure
stellar mass black holes we can't
measure the kind of black holes that
ligo is looking at because they are too
small i mean we're at the very limits
right so even if there were a stellar
mass black hole in our neighborhood it
would still be too small because the
ones that we're looking at here are
millions and billions of times the mass
of our sun so they have very big event
horizons these are the largest event
horizons that we're likely to see in the
night sky
at the same time
it's wonderful
that we now have
confirmation of einstein's theories for
stellar mass black holes
then we have confirmation that you see
here
for a four million solar mass black hole
and then also for an eight a six and a
half billion solar mass black hole
when you think about it there's no other
object that we know of
that can be basically the same object
but scale up by a factor of a billion
i mean imagine taking a mouse
and scaling a mouse up to be a billion
times what it was it would just it
couldn't support itself the skeletal
structure the muscles it would just
dissolve into a big puddle
but somehow black holes
are so simple
and they're so universal
they're so mathematical you can have one
that weighs
10 times the mass of our sun and one
that weighs
6 billion times the mass of our sun that
shows that einstein's gravity and his
theory holds over
many orders of magnitude it's really a
wonder
of modern physics yeah and you know from
a theoretical standpoint you could
actually have a black hole going back to
a piece of fruit that has the same mass
as an orange right if you took an orange
according to the classical theory and
squashed it down to a sufficiently small
size you know to a size less than 2g m
over c squared then you would have an
orange masked black hole as well so it
is a
remarkable
confluence between
the simple mathematics and simple by the
scales that we're talking about here
and these real qualities of the universe
so it is utterly remarkable so so where
do you where do you see your work going
from here are are there are there
particular uh targets where you feel you
might be able to say push einstein's
theory even further are there certain
astrophysical puzzles that you hope to
gain some insight into through this kind
of imaging brian
we're just getting started i mean we're
going to be studying these images
refining these techniques for years to
come i think it's fair to say that we've
created
almost a whole new field precision
measurements of black holes on horizon
scales and we're we're we're just not
going to stop
we're we're putting the the pedal to the
metal so
the the real promising areas that i see
here
is studying
for one the substructure of this ring so
we see this tufty ring we see this
slightly out of focus ring
but if you go more deeply into
einstein's theory you realize that that
ring should consist of an infinite
number of sub rings
so we're mostly seeing light that has
been gently bent if you will around the
black hole
but some of that light then does a
u-turn around the black hole and that
will be that'll spend more time close
into the high gravity and will be
thinner and fainter and will be interior
to that ring the first ring then there
are some that will do a full orbit
around the black hole that will create
an even finer ring
also fainter because fewer photons can
make that torturous voyage
and there will be another ring interior
to that and another ring interior to
that each getting successively closer to
the photon orbit each
more faint each with a perfectly defined
mathematical curve
now
the limit in how well we can test
einstein right now is all the messy gas
that makes this image
tufty
if we can measure the first photon ring
the the first ring interior to this
that would give us to like the one
percent level
for testing einstein and the way to do
that is to increase the frequency of our
observations which would increase the
angular resolution
and to put more telescopes on the
surface of the earth if we were to do
that we could
tease out the first of those rings and
that's what we call the next generation
eht instrument so we have some design
funding now
from foundations and from the national
science foundation to build this
and design this new array which will be
different from the eht because where the
eht we used electronics at existing
sites
now we want to build new dishes at
optimal sites it's it's so exciting
brian because now we can
really let loose and ask ourselves where
would we put telescopes on the surface
of the earth if we could put them
anywhere
and we're optimizing that now to pull
out that that inner ring oh that's
amazing and how many how many dishes
well obviously the more the merrier but
how many dishes do you imagine starting
out with in the new network
well how how much money do you have yeah
right exactly that's always the question
right
um
i think that if we had the simulations
we've run show that if we had double the
number of dishes that we have now going
to about 20 dishes
that we would be able to refine
the event horizon telescope results in
in two ways we'd be able to see this
first ring
so testing einstein
at a much higher level of precision but
we'd also be able to
pan back
and see the m87 jet for example in its
full glory so right now we only see the
black hole we know there's this big jet
that goes out that we see in the optical
with hubble you know we see it at longer
wavelength radio maps but we can't make
the connection
between the black hole and that
cosmic blowtorch and that's important
because we don't understand now how the
black hole powers
that jet is it a spinning black hole
with magnetic fields locked onto it like
propeller blades launching charged
particles at near light speeds is it
something else is it the accretion flow
that's doing it
this is an open mystery and
understanding that
will unlock
this unknown of how these black holes
reprocess matter and energy on galactic
scales that's really a primary feedback
mechanism that governs how galaxies
evolve
and so we want to make our first movies
of black holes by adding 10 new dishes
we should be able to make the first
movies
black hole cinema coming to a theater
near you so like your your own version
of interstellar and actually i wanted to
ask you about that and i hope this isn't
a question that's sort of out of school
but i had an experience and i wonder if
you've had a similar one when your first
image came out of the black hole in m87
i was
explaining
it to someone i was showing to them
and
i was having trouble getting them
excited because they were like well
you know it's a little blurry and
they're used to the cinematic version
that you see you know in hollywood and
this high-end animation so
did you find any difficulty in getting
the excitement that these images should
engender in the public because of the
fact that hollywood beat you there first
with you know these wonderful animated
versions of black holes you know i i get
that a little bit you know people ask
like why is this so blurry and i have to
explain to them well it's blurry because
it's as sharp as we can make it i mean
this is
the sharpest image that we have ever
made
in the history of astronomy
and it's blurry because we are at our
absolute limits and when i explain it
like that when i explain that
you know a team of scientists working
across borders turning the earth into a
telescope
getting getting petabytes of data back
crunching it together drawing expertise
from from many different fields and then
we were just able to get our first
glimpse of something that we thought was
impossible
that usually gets people satisfied yeah
and we're just getting started and now
we're going to make movies and we're
going to refine this and it's going to
happen like within the average lifetime
of an average astronomer
that gets people excited
so you want to explain to them how hard
it was you want to explain to them that
it's our job to explain what we saw that
were explorers you know taking these
voyages to
virtually to these different distant
galaxies and we want to come back and
explain to them what we're doing and
that we have a plan to make it better
that
is very uplifting for people so i i it
takes a minute but once you explain all
this
to someone who's truly curious they get
it they just get it so it's incredibly
exciting work and i just can't wait to
see
what emerges from your future studies as
you go forward if it was up to me i'd
give you a hundred dishes around the
earth so you know the uh the excitement
is there and the the potential for
breakthrough is enormous and and just a
great congratulations both to you and to
the entire event horizon telescope for
these really wonderful achievements well
thanks brian it's been a real pleasure
thanks thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you